c'est la protection des épargnants
monsieur le Président
présenté par Jean-François Husson et
albéric de Montgolfier sur la demande du
groupe les républicains
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Monsieur albéric de Montgolfier
auteur de la proposition de loi pour 10
minutes
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur président de
la commission des finances nous allons
maintenant examiner une proposition de
loi qui n'a rien à voir avec appel lui
intercommunal mais c'est une proposition
de loi qui est portée par le rapporteur
général Jean-François Husson et par
moi-même et qui je le précise est le
résultat d'un long processus que nous
avons engagé dès 2020 sur le thème de la
protection des épargnants
ce marathon si je puis dire vu le nombre
de d'auditions je l'ai d'abord engagé en
tant que rapporteur général dans un
contexte qui était à l'époque fort
différent d'aujourd'hui puisque c'était
un contexte de taux bas et de
constitution d'une épargne forcée le
contexte évidemment depuis 2020 depuis
le début de ses auditions a changé
puisque nous sommes aujourd'hui avec une
épargne toujours élevée mais avec une
inflation forte et néanmoins les
recommandations que nous avions
formulées pour certaines dès le début
reste toujours d'actualité
la proposition de loi que nous avons à
Jean-François Husson et moi-même déposés
en mars dernier se situe dans le
prolongement direct de notre rapport
d'information publié au mois d'octobre
2021 et qui avait donné lieu à 17
recommandations de niveau normatifs
variés les 12 articles initiaux de la
proposition de loi sont directement
tirées des recommandations de nature
législatives de ce rapport
au terme d'une quinzaine d'auditions ils
ont été modifiés améliorés et compléter
au stade de l'examen en commission par
20 amendements dont 8 portant
additionnels je salue ici Monsieur le
Ministre et les échanges constructifs
que nous avons pu avoir avec bien sûr
vos services mais également avec le
ministère les autorités de supervision
que ce soit l'Autorité des marchés
financiers ou l'Autorité de contrôle
prudentiel et de résolution
les constats que nous dressions il y a
un an et demi dans notre rapport n'ont
pas changé le marché de l'épargne est
certes dynamique mais il se distingue
également par la prédominance du marché
historique de la banque assurance ce qui
nuit à la concurrence et par des frais
qui sont plus élevés que la moyenne
européenne ces constats sont d'autant
plus d'actualité que vous le savez
l'inflation atteint 5,2% en moyenne en
2022 et cela devient un facteur
supplémentaire d'érosion de l'épargne
des Français je parlais à l'important à
l'instant de l'importance des frais par
exemple pour une épargne de plus de 30
ans plus de la moitié plus de la moitié
des des du résultat est capté par des
frais alors comment faire dès lors pour
mieux protéger les épargnants la
propulsion de loi répond à cet objectif
par 20 articles regroupés dans quatre
chapitres le premier porte sur
l'encadrement plus strict de certaines
catégories de commissions avec même la
suppression des commissions de
spécificités françaises le deuxième
chapitre entend répondre aux épargnants
leur permettant de faire un choix plus
éclairé dans la sélection de leurs
produits le troisième chapitre qu'on
prend des dispositions destinées à lever
les contraintes sur les produits
d'épargne et à stimuler la concurrence
tandis que le dernier chapitre regroupe
les dispositifs de nature à permettre de
mieux encadrer les marchés les acteurs
du marché de l'épargne
je concentrerai mon intervention sur le
premier et quatrième chapitre laissant
au rapporteur général le soin de
présenter les autres chapitres
de d'abord sur les frais je le rappelais
alors même que la part de la performance
captée par les frais et de plus en plus
élevés à long terme au détriment des
épargnants les articles 1 et 2 de la
propulsion de loi viennent soutenir un
meilleur encadrement de ses frais
l'article premier interdit les
commissions de mouvement les épargnants
doivent en effet s'acquitter en plus des
frais de transaction de ces commissions
et subissent à cet égard une double
charge et ces commissions portent
également un risque inhérent de conflit
d'intérêt les gestionnaires peuvent être
un effet incité à faire tourner plus les
portefeuilles faire plus d'achat vente
sans que cela se fasse uniquement au
bénéfice de l’épargnant elles sont une
spécificité voir une accroburgité
Française et nous ne félicitons que
depuis nos travaux l'Autorité des
marchés financiers l'AMF est modifié son
règlement général pour les interdire à
partir des 1er janvier 2026 donc depuis
le dépôt de notre texte cela a sans
doute contribué de manière on a servi de
Vienne négociation supplémentaire et
nous avons donc obtenu gain de cause sur
un sujet majeur c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous vous proposerons tout à
l'heure d'entériner cette modification
du règlement général de l'AMF en
supprimant l'article 1 je pense que nous
avons en effet obtenu gain de cause
l'article 2 propose quant à lui
d'introduire une définition de
l'arbitrage et du mandat d'arbitrage
dans le code des assurances pourquoi cet
article
d'apparence technique il y a cela deux
justifications simple il faut opérer un
rapprochement réglementaire entre les
produits assurantiels et les produits
financiers d'une part et il faut par
ailleurs mettre fin à syndrome de
pratique hétérogène après le passage en
commission il est désormais maintenant
pleinement conforme au droit européen
mais aussi pris du tranchant puisque je
lisais c'est l'interdit les
commissairesceptions de commission de
mouvement par les mandataires j'aborde
maintenant le chapitre 4 les autres
étant abordés par Jean-François le
chapitre 4 qui contient les dispositions
visant à mieux encadrer les acteurs et
les interm sur le marché de l’épargne
l'article 10 vis-initialement a confié à
lorias alors vous n'avez peut-être pas
familier de lorias Lauria c'est
l'organisme
de registre unique qui vise les
intermédiaires en assurance banque et
finance donc il contrôle notamment leur
honorabilité
des dirigeants des salariés des
intermédiaires et nous avons été
convaincus par les auditions que nous
avons menées que l'ORIAS ne disposait
pas des moyens nécessaires d'assurer sa
mission il Nord demeure pas moins que le
modèle actuel qui est basé sur un
contrôle par les associations
professionnelles et qu'ils inspirent de
l'armée régulation qui est mise en place
pour les conseillers notamment en
épargne financier n'est pas optimale et
suscite un certain nombre
d'interrogations sur un risque de
complaisance par exemple j'avais évoqué
ces risques devant vous lors de l'examen
de l'approvision de loi référentive à la
réforme du courtage en assurance dont
j'étais rapporteur et j'y m'y tiens pour
que ce modèle de coagulation fonctionne
il faut encore les associations
professionnelles elles-mêmes soient
contrôlées et c'est le rôle de
l'autorité de contrôle prudentielle et
de religion la CPR qui jusqu'à
maintenant faisait très peu de contrôle
les travaux que nous avons menés sur
l'article 11 nous ont permis d'aborder
d'arriver je pense à un compromis
satisfaisant sur un sujet majeur celui
de l'encadrement des investissements
défiscalisés dans le secteur locatif
vous savez en France on paye beaucoup
d'impôts sans doute mais on a également
on aime également beaucoup les
réductions d'impôts parfois un peu trop
et tous les ministres du logement nous
ont expliqué qu'ils allaient résoudre la
question de la crise du logement en
attachant leur nom à un dispositif
fiscal alors voilà tout le Pinel mais
tous les tous les ministres de droite de
gauche le périssoles etc ont inventé le
Bouvard le Sancy on peut les citer et
nous ont expliqué que c'était dispositif
qui allaient permettre définitivement de
résoudre la crise du logement et il est
fort cette constater que à certain
nombre d'intermédiaire
vendent ces produits départs
immobilière défiscalisé en oubliant
parfois un peu de rappeler aux
investisseurs aux épargnants le risque
cela comporte on vous vend la réduction
de la peau quand vous regardez les
publicités vous voyez payer moins
d'impôts on n'oublie pas
de dire que c'est un investissement dans
le terme qu'il y a des charges de
remboursement on vous dit rendement
garantir on vous dit risque locatif 0
tout ça évidemment n'existe pas et
aujourd'hui ce secteur n'est pas encadré
et vous avez sans doute vous voyez vu
sur internet des publicités pour
investir dans des villes parfois dans
des quartiers qui sont inconnus où il y
a pas de besoin je suis avec ma présence
de la commission des finances à l'époque
qui était originaire d'Auvergne et de
parler d'investissement et du logement
étudiant à Riom c'est un peu de mal à se
ensuite ça se placer et donc avec des
promesses de rendement extraordinaire
alors aujourd'hui les investisseurs ne
sont pas suffisamment avertis des
risques et parfois des offres
frauduleuses qui mineur ou qui font
abstraction des des risques en
les vendeurs se concentrent en effet sur
l'avantage fiscal sans mentionner le
risque pour le patrimoine ni resquif
fiscal et je crois que nous pourrions
monsieur le ministre ne plus laisser ces
pratiques perdurer nous proposons donc
titre de cette article 11 un encadrement
plus strict des hommes du travail des
intermédiaires avec des exigences en
matière de publicité qui seraient
renforcées pour indiquer l'ensemble des
risques d'investissement avec une notice
d'information qui devra être
obligatoirement remis à l'épargnant et
avec un manquement surtout qui devrait
qui pourrait être sanctionné par les
agents de la DGCCRF de la Direction
Générale de la Concurrence de la
Consommation et la réfraction des
fraudes qui pourront infliger des
amendes administratives alors nous
souhaitons allier plus loin nous avons
examiné avec l'AMF la possibilité de
aller vers un contrôle plus accru il est
en effet paradoxal je rappelais le
montant des produits des plans
en matière des 44000 euros en matière
d'épargne et sur l'investissement
immobilier on évidemment sur nous sommes
qui sont beaucoup plus importantes et
paradoxalement il y a moins de contrôle
et donc nous avons maintenu vraiment de
rapport pour évaluer les moyens
nécessaires à la mise en place d'un
contrôle systématique des offres de
publicité des documents contractuels qui
constituera une première étape je
l'espère vers un contrôle a priori de
ces offres donc nous avons je crois une
tâche immense mieux réguler ce secteur
en tous les cas dans le sens de la
protection des épargnants et c'est
également le sens de l'article 12 qui
vise à s'assurer que les acteurs du
financement participatifs sont bien
soumis à des obligations des cratives au
titre de lutte contre le blanchiment
voilà je laisse Jean-François isson
puisque mon temps est écoulé le choix de
vous le présenter les autres aspects
j'espère mes chers collègues que vous
souscrirez à cette provision de loi qui
vise à mieux protéger les épargnants
dans un contexte de hausse des taux et
dans un contexte en tous les cas de
recherche de rendement c'est aussi les
moyens de mieux protéger les Français
notamment en diminuant les frais je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant
au rapporteur de la commission des
finances Jean-François Husson qui a
également 10 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues prenant à
l'instant le relais de mon collègue
albéric de Montgolfier permettez-moi
également et d'abord de saluer la
qualité de nos échanges avec le
ministère et les autorités de
supervision ainsi que l'importance de
nos travaux complémentaires sur cette
proposition de loi nous avons entendu de
nombreux acteurs avec qui nous n'étions
d'ailleurs pas toujours en accord même
si nous poursuivions le même but
protéger davantage les épargnants cet
objectif fidèle est au cœur des
chapitres 2 et 3 de cette proposition de
loi que je m'apprête à vous présenter
sur les frais d'abord nous avons deux
moyens d'agir le premier albéric de
Montgolfier en a parlé avec l'article
premier c'est celui d'interdire ceux qui
nous paraissent
inopportuns ou redondant le deuxième
moyen d'action indirect mais aussi très
efficace consiste à garantir les
conditions d'un choix éclairé pour les
épar
en assurant une transparence accrue sur
la performance des produits en tenant
compte de tous les frais les épargnants
seront alors en mesure de choisir les
produits les plus rentables et adaptés à
leurs besoins quand nous parlons de ces
informations on ne fait pas référence à
un document qui manquerait de lisibilité
ne facilitant pas d'ailleurs la
compréhension document que l'épargnant
au mieux rapidement dans un tiroir
lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il rentre chez lui
non l'affichage du coup complet des
produits doit conduire
à entretenir et à stimuler la
concurrence entre les acteurs et exercer
une pression à la baisse sur les frais
l'article 3 impose tout d'abord au
distributeurs d'assurance vie et aux
gestionnaires des plans des pannes
retraite de présenter lors de la
constitution d'un contrat ou d'un plan
les fonds indiciels côté disponibles
pourquoi ces produits en particulier
parce que c'est fond le plus souvent
d'ailleurs en gestion passive présente
un niveau de frais généralement
inférieur au fond en gestion active pour
une performance nette en moyenne égale
ou supérieure or ces fonds ne sont
quasiment jamais proposés à la
souscription parce que trop peu rentable
pour les distributeurs et les
conseillers leur présentation pourrait
donc entretenir une scène compétition et
il est vraiment temps que les
distributeurs se saisissent de ce sujet
ils prennent le risque sinon
de se voir dépasser par les nouveaux
acteurs qui eux proposent des fonds
indiciels côtés avec en plus une
souscription sur internet je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit vraiment mieux pour les
épargnants et je préférais que les
distributeurs que je qualifierais de
traditionnels qui ont la confiance des
épargnants sans part pleinement du sujet
l'article 4 permet quant à lui de
remédier un obstacle que nous
connaissons de longue date à savoir
l'impossibilité de disposer d'une
information claire sur les frais totaux
des produits financiers désormais
l'ensemble des épargnants pourront
accéder à une information lisible
publiée sur les sites internet
d'établissements et par ailleurs les
informations communiquées aux
contractants ne se baseront plus
seulement sur la performance annuelle
mais sur la performance pluriannuelle
des produits dans le même temps le
comité consultatif du secteur financier
dans un format d'ailleurs rappelant
celui de l'Observatoire des tarifs
bancaires sera chargé de suivre les
pratiques tarifaires de l'assurance vie
et des plans d'épargne en action ouvrant
la voie à une comparabilité objective
des produits
je crois que Monsieur le Ministre
partagera cet avis cet article est
capital il constitue une véritable
avancée au service de la transparence et
de la bonne information des épargnants
les unités de compte seront classées par
performance nette c'est plus lisible
pour chacun à charge ensuite et c'est
normal au conseiller de faire son
travail pour constituer le panier de
produits le plus approprié comme l’ont
d'ailleurs souligné rappeler nos
collègues en commission peu de personnes
peuvent spontanément comprendre ce que
l'on veut dire par valeur brute
encadracha ou plus-value potentiel ce
sont des informations je dirais plus
concrètes dont ont besoin les épargnants
je passe désormais au chapitre 3 de
notre proposition de loi relative au
développement à l'adaptation des
produits d'épargne nous pouvons en fait
ici distinguer deux types d'articles
ceux qui lèvent les contraintes pesant
sur certains produits d'épargne et ceux
qui tendent envisager ou encouragé une
véritable concurrence sur le marché de
l'épargne concernant les premiers
rapidement l'article 5 propose un droit
à l'erreur sur le PE avec la possibilité
pour l'épargnant de ne pas perdre
davantage fiscal s'il vient à corriger
son erreur par exemple d'achat de titres
non éligibles au PEA en complément
l'article 5 bis vise à assouplir
légèrement le champ des titres éligibles
au PA pour favoriser l'accessibilité des
produits de capital risque encore trop
méconnu sur le développement du capital
investissement la Commission a sur notre
proposition supprimer l'article 6 qui
portait sur le dispositif Madelin dont
nous avons eu l'occasion de débattre
récemment dans le cas du dernier projet
de loi de finances preuve de notre bonne
foi monsieur le ministre nous sommes
d'ailleurs prêts à attendre les
résultats d'évaluation de ce dispositif
avant de proposer de nouvelles mesures
concernant l'encouragement de la
concurrence sur le marché de l'épargne
j'en viens à cet instant un sujet qui
nous est particulièrement cher et qui ne
manquera pas j'en suis sûr de susciter
quelques débats c'est l'article 7 et la
transfurabilité des contrats d'assurance
vie il comporte deux volets relatifs à
la fois à la transférabilité interne
d'une part et externe d'autre part il
s'agit d'abord de lever les obstacles au
développement de la transférabilité
interne que l'assuré pourra demander à
tout moment à l'assureur ou à
l'intermédiaire lequel sera désormais
tenu de réaliser le transfert dans les
deux mois
et bien après le passage en commission
cet article consacre désormais un droit
au transfert interne sans possibilité
pour les assureurs de s'y opposés tout
en limitant les frais pouvant être
imposés lors de cette opération faire du
transfert interne un droit vraiment
opposable est un progrès indéniable les
dispositions que nous vous proposons
permettrons de donner leur pleine portée
à ce que nous avions d'ailleurs voté
dans le cadre la loi pacte déjà et
d'ailleurs à ce moment-là on nous
prédisait que le transfert interne
allait conduire à l'écroulement du
marché de l'assurance vie et à une forte
instabilité financière tout le monde s'y
est opposé et nous voilà trois ans plus
tard à renforcer unanimement la portée
ce dispositif sans surprise j'ose le
dire nous faisons face aujourd'hui au
même prix d'offrait avec la
transférabilité externe
le second volet de l'article 7 autorise
en effet le transfert externe des
contrats d'assurance vie avec
portabilité de l'antériorité fiscale à
peine proposé ces dispositions à créer
de vif débat avant même que nous ayons
eu le temps de présenter les garde-fous
prévues pour l'encadrer il convient
d'avoir une vision nuancée des
conséquences attendues de cette mesure
elle ne porterait que sur les contrats
de plus de 8 ans et surtout elle
pourrait améliorer la qualité des
conseils prodigués aux épargnants ces
derniers auraient d'ailleurs d'autant
moins de raisons de quitter leur
intermédiaire ou leur assureur si ce
dernier vient alors proposer des
produits plus appropriés plus rentables
que ceux souscrit initialement prenons
un exemple des contraintes qui pèsent
sur les épargnants en l'absence de
transférabilité personne n'avait entendu
parler des produits verts il y a 10 ans
maintenant de plus en plus d'épargnants
veulent verdir leur épargne et soutenir
la transition écologique monsieur le
ministre
allons-nous leur dire qu'ils sont prises
daniés d'un produit souscrit il y a des
années et qui ne peuvent pas réorienter
leur épargne si c'est votre position
vous êtes has been notre objectif ici
est donc simple évitez aux épargnants
d'être captifs et de suscité une plus
grande concurrence ce qui encouragerait
d'ailleurs en amont des pratiques de
conseils plus actives et plus adaptées
aux besoins des assurés de la part des
intermédiaires et des assureurs et
d'ailleurs préciser qu'en cas de rachat
du contrat l'assureur peut évidemment
proposer à l'assuré des options de
transfert interne pour conclure sans
renforcement de la transférabilité
externe nous d'habiterions qu'il y a une
transférabilité interne boiteuse et si
vous me permettez de filer la métaphore
je dirais que seul leur conjonction
permettra à la liberté de choix de
l'épargnant de marcher sur ces deux
jambes et de l'exercice pleinement dans
cette même optique la commission
introduit l'article 7 bis qui est un
situe à deux barres de conseils dans la
durée pour les intermédiaires et les
assureurs
encore une fois d'adapter l'offre aux
épargnant à l'évolution de son profil
c'est l'article 7 TER qui vise lui à
prévoir expressément une obligation de
respect des engagements contractuels en
cours d'exécution pour les deux articles
du chapitre 3 on aborde les sujets des
plans des bras de retraite bien que bien
sûr sans que cela ne doivent préempter
le débat que nous aurons prochainement
l'article 8 enfin proge jusqu'en 2026
l'incitation fiscale mise en place pour
encourager le transfert de l'épargne
investie dans un contrat d'assurance vie
l'article 9 confie à la Caisse des
Dépôts la gestion d'un fond de fond
indiciel côté qui serait ensuite
distribué dans les per il s'agit tout
simplement de proposer un produit peu
chargé en frais aux épargnants monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je vous
remercie de votre attention j'espère que
vous soutiendrez toutes et tous notre
démarche qui ne fait en fait que
protéger les particuliers en améliorant
développement encourageant et en
soutenant le marché de l'épargne en
France le chemin est ouvert ne perdons
pas de temps et sachons les uns les
autres être au rendez-vous de la
responsabilité merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur général et
maintenant à part le tout ministre qui
va relever le défi de la modernité
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs nous sommes
réunis pour examiner la proposition de
loi des sénateurs hussons et Mongolfier
un texte qui propose de renforcer la
protection des épargnants via une série
de mesures articulée autour d'un
triptyque informations protection
répression je d'ores et déjà vous dire
qu'il contient y compris après examen en
commission plusieurs mesures que le
Gouvernement salue à vrai dire le
gouvernement accueille très
favorablement cette proposition de loi
qui vient compléter un certain nombre
d'évolutions récentes au bénéfice des
épargnants à l'exception de deux
articles notamment qui vous feront
peut-être dire messieurs et rapporteur
que je suis un peu has been mais j'aurai
l'occasion à la fois à la tribune et
tout à l'heure dans le débat
expliquer la position du Gouvernement
sur ces articles en matière
d'information sur le contenu et les
frais des produits financiers le
Gouvernement partage pleinement les
objectifs de la proposition de loi
exprimée en particulier dans l'article
premier et les articles 3 et 4 l'article
premier supprime les commissions de
mouvement qui sont souvent peu
transparentes restreintes à un petit
nombre de produits et qui altère la
qualité globale de l'information sur les
frais de gestion figurant dans la
documentation commerciale l'article 3 en
créant une obligation de présentation
des ETF produits simples et peu chargés
proposés sur le contrat d'assurance vie
ou sur le plan d'épargne retraite
permettra de développer une classe
d'actifs encore peu présente et incitera
les gestionnaires d'actifs français à
développer leur offre cette mesure est
absolument fondamentale tant les ETF
sont un moyen pour les épargnants
français
d'accéder à des produits
faible en coût mais dont la performance
suit les les grands indices et donc leur
garantie une forme de de performance qui
soit au minimum la même que celle des
marchés d'action l'article 4 permet de
poursuivre les efforts de la loi pacte
pour en forme c'est la transparence des
frais des contrats d'assurance vie et
des plans d'épargne retraite cette
transparence accrue permettra de
stimuler la concurrence au sein du
secteur et d'exercer une pression à la
baisse par conséquent sur le niveau des
frais pour stimuler le rendement de
l'épargne
par ailleurs nous saluons la création
d'un observatoire de l'épargne qui sera
donc portée par le comité consultatif du
secteur financier ces trois mesures sont
de nature à permettre aux consommateurs
de faire un choix mieux éclairé au
moment d'alouer son épargne parmi les
différents supports d'investissement
le texte permet également d'encadrer
certaines pratiques renforçant ainsi la
protection des épargnants ainsi la
création d'un mandat d'arbitrage en
assurance vie à l'article de confère des
garantisses supplémentaires à
l'épargnant dans un contexte où les
pratiques du marché sont hétérogènes le
Gouvernement partage l'objectif
poursuivi par les rapporteurs et
proposera d'apporter des modifications
concernant le champ d'application les
obligations du mandataire et la place
des prestataires de services
d'investissement le texte propose
également de renforcer significativement
le dispositif de contrôle des offres de
vente de biens immobiliers dans le cadre
de dispositifs fiscaux le gouvernement
soutient cette proposition à l'exception
de celle d'un rapport d'évaluation sur
ces dispositions en effet ce rapport ne
semble pas utile compte tenu de la
transparence donnée par la DGCCRF sur le
bilan de ces enquêtes par ailleurs les
évaluations de ce type en matière
d'effectif sont très régulièrement
demandés par le Parlement dans le cadre
de travaux afférents au projet de loi de
finances
le Parlement a ainsi toute l'attitude à
droit constant pour solliciter ces
informations le moment venu en matière
répressive le gouvernement se félicite
du renforcement des pouvoirs d'enquête
de l'Autorité des marchés financiers par
l'adaptation de ses compétences aux
évolutions des offres de produits
financiers et aux pratiques de marché la
crédibilité de l'AMF est essentielle au
maintien de l'intégrité du marché qui
est le socle de la confiance des
épargnants dont la participation est
nécessaire pour contribuer au
financement de l'économie concernant la
lutte contre le blanchiment l'article 12
renforce les obligations déclaratives en
matière de financement participatif sur
une fraction des acteurs qui n'était pas
encore couverte le financement des parts
sociales votre proposition permet de
combler cette lacune je veux salue au
nom du gouvernement les rapporteurs pour
leur écoute et le travail préliminaire
menait conjointement avec Bruno Le Maire
qui a permis d'enrichir le texte et d'en
renforcer sur certains aspects
l'ambition je pense notamment au travail
fructueux mené sur les dispositions
concernant la transparence des frais ces
travaux ont contribué à renforcer du
texte par exemple à travers la mise en
place de l'Observatoire de l'épargne
chargée de suivre l'évolution des frais
de l'épargnation ancienne mais aussi des
PEA et des PEA PME sur le régime de
contrôle des offres immobilières je
remercie aussi les rapporteurs pour la
qualité des échanges et salut les
avancées du texte adopté en commission
et permise grâce à ce travail conjoint
enfin je pense à la proposition des
rapports pour renforcer la protection
des assurés grâce à la clarification des
obligations d'exécution des obligations
contractuelles en cours de contrat
cependant le gouvernement conserve une
divergence d'appréciation concernant
l'article 7 visant entre autres à mettre
en place un droit à la transfertilité
externe des contrats d'assurance vie
étant entendu qu'il accueille
favorablement le renforcement proposé
par les rapporteurs de la transfertilité
interne de ces contrats d'assurance vie
la mise en place de la transfertilité
externe constitue un risque significatif
pour la stabilité financière et le
financement de l'économie en période de
remontée des taux comme à l'heure
actuelle les transferts obligeraient les
assureurs à aller réaliser les
moins-values latentes en liquidant des
obligations pour servir les demandes des
assurés la transfertilité externe
créerait une situation de concurrence
déloyale en bénéficiant à de nouvelles
entreprises des entreprises entrantes en
capacité d'investir dans des obligations
à taux plus élevées qui pourraient ainsi
capter les épargnants des assureurs
établies et mettre en danger leur
situation prudentielle les épargnants
seraient les premiers perdants de la
transfertilité externe le rendement de
l'épargne serait mécaniquement réduit
car l'actif des assureurs s'orienterait
vers des placements liquides et des
obligations à maturité plus courtes pour
faire face à la demande accrue de rachat
des épargnants l'encadrement prévu par
l'article est insuffisant pour limiter
ses risques la limitation de la
possibilité de transferts au contrat de
temps et plus est insuffisante car ces
contrats représentent 70% du total des
encours d'assurance vie cette mesure est
d'autant plus regrettable que comme je
le disais le même article propose la
mise en place d'un droit à la
transfertilité interne la loi pacte
ouvrez cette possibilité là la
proposition de loi qui est soumise à
votre examen en créer un droit cette
évolution constitue une piste
prometteuse qui ira donc au bout de la
logique de la loi pacte
à l'article 9 la création d'un fonds de
fond indiciel côté dont la gestion
serait confiée à la Caisse des dépôts et
consignations n'apparaît pas opportune
car de tels produits sont proposés par
des acteurs privés et je viens de
rappeler à quel point il est important à
mon sens que c'est produit là les
produits indiciels puissent se
développer et dans l'intérêt général que
les initiatives de la Caisse des Dépôts
ne soient pas redondantes à Excel du
secteur privé afin qu'elle garde des
marges de manœuvre pour jouer un rôle
contracyclique lorsque cela est
nécessaire afin de répondre aux
objectifs visés par la proposition
stimuler le développement d'une offre de
per au niveau de frais contenu serait
plus pertinent vous l'avez compris ces
deux articles c'était 9 seront les
principaux points de discussion que le
gouvernement vous soumettra pendant
l'examen que nous allons débuter je vous
remercie
monsieur le ministre la discussion
générale se poursuit avec la parole à
Georges patient pour le groupe RDPI et
pour 6 minutes
je suis le président
monsieur le ministre messieurs les
rapporteurs
les frais encore pointés du doigt
l'accumulation des frais élevés peut
dans certains cas amputer toute
espérance de rendement
ces mots prononcés début décembre par
Jean-Paul fougères le vice-président du
collège de supervision de l'Autorité de
contrôle prudentiel et de résolution à
ses prières le gendarme des banques et
assureurs ces mots
prononcés indiquent une fois de plus
combien la question des frais notamment
dans l'assurance vie reste problématique
le président Faugère préciser également
que la mention des frais appliqués au
plan et pas de retraite et assurance vie
désormais obligatoire depuis le 1er juin
2022 sur les sites Internet des
établissements n'avaient pas contribué à
leur baisse bien au contraire si bien
qu'une nouvelle recommandation des
autorités aux professionnels sur ce
point était attendu courant 2023
c'est dire que cette proposition de loi
présentée par nos rapporteur et auteurs
Jean-François hussant et albéric de
Montgolfier arrive à point nommé dans
cette quête dans cet appel à une plus
grande protection des épargnants
issus de leur rapport d'information sur
la protection des épargnants dont elle
traduit les principales recommandations
de niveau législatif on peut aisément
concevoir que cette PPL fait consensus a
fortiori parce qu'elle reprend les
conclusions d'une mission de contrôle
sénatorial transparciane
les rapporteurs en 1900 sont un certain
nombre de problèmes qui pénalisent
lourdement les épargnies en français je
citerai une concurrence entre acteurs
limité un nombre élevé d'intermédiaire
ou encore un faible développement de la
gestion passive
ces structuration du marché de départ se
traduit ainsi par un niveau de frais
élevé qui pèse sur la performance servie
aux épargnants
et certains des acteurs auditionnés ont
tenu un discours particulièrement
radical sur l'état du marché de
l'épargne je pense notamment à la
pratique des commissions de mouvement
que l'article premier propose
d'interdire et qui a été vertement
dénoncé par un certain nombre d'acteurs
les épargnants subissent en effet une
double fracturation à chaque opération
avec les frais de courtage et les
commissions de mouvement chaque année ce
sont 500 millions d'euros qui sont
prélevés indument par les sociétés de
gestion et les intermédiaires alors que
ces pratiques sont interdites dans les
autres juridictions européennes
les rapporteurs ont déposé en commission
vers amendement sur leur propre texte
tous les articles initiaux ont été
réécris et certains articles
additionnels ajoutés signe que le
dialogue des rapporteurs avec Bercy a
été constructif
trois articles sont néanmoins soulever
des interrogations au sein de mon groupe
le premier concerne le droit à l'erreur
fiscale en cas de placement de titre non
éligible sur un PEA ou un PEA PME que je
instauré l'article 5 n'y a-t-il pas là
un risque d'inciter à placer des titres
non éligibles sur un PEA afin de
bénéficier de ses avantages fiscaux tout
en rejetant la faute sur le gestionnaire
le second sujet porte sur l'article 7 et
la transférabilité à tout moment de
contrat d'assurance vie entre assureur
je doute qu'une telle mesure conduise à
une réelle amélioration des tarifs des
assurances vie pour les assurer en
revanche elle pourrait s'avérer
défavorable au financement de l'économie
en contraignant les assureurs à préférer
les placements de très court terme et
sans risque afin de pouvoir clôturer à
tout moment en contrat enfin proposer un
placement de départ de retraite à
l'article 9 en plein débat sur la
refaire sur la réforme des retraites
opportun même si la gestion confie à la
Caisse des Dépôts serait plus chargée en
frais
aussi si nous saluons le travail des
rapporteurs qui dans l'ensemble va dans
le sens d'une meilleure protection des
épargnants nous espérons que la qualité
de nos débats permettra de lever les
doutes qui subsistent sur les sujets que
je viens d'évoquer
je ne saurais terminer mon propos sans
faire mention des Outre-mer
tous les habitants d'outre-mer doivent
payer leurs produits financier plus cher
qu'en France métropolitaine 10% tel est
le surcoût que nos compatriotes
ultramarins doivent payer à leur banque
en comparaison avec l'Hexagone c'est ce
que des voies une étude menée par
l'association des consommateurs CLCV
contrairement aux tarif bancaires
l'opacité des frais appliqués à
l'épargne nous empêche encore d'avoir un
état des lieux précis j'espère que le
comparateur officiel est arrivé
bancaires tenus par le comité
consultatif du secteur financier sera
rapidement enrichi avec les données
publiées pour les per et assurances vie
dont je parlais au début de mon propos
je remercie
et maintenant la parole est à Rémi
Féraud pour le groupe CER et pour 9
minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
nous examinons donc cet après-midi une
proposition de loi tendant à renforcer
la protection des épargnants à
l'initiative d'Albéric de Montgolfier et
de Jean-François Husson collègue que je
veux remercier pour leur travail mené au
nom de notre commission elle comprend de
nombreuses mesures souvent techniques
que le groupe socialiste a soutenu la
création par exemple d'une définition
harmonisée de l'arbitrage en assurance
vie qui est une avancée positive alors
qu'aujourd'hui les opérateurs disposent
chacun de la leur et ce dans une grande
opacité pour leurs clients
l'instauration d'un devoir de conseil
dans la durée pour les intermédiaires et
les assureurs qui permettra d'adapter
les offres proposées à l'assuré en
fonction de l'évolution de son profil et
de ses besoins cette obligation qui
s'appliquerait donc à l'occasion de
toute opération susceptibles susceptible
d'infecter le contrat renforce ainsi la
protection des épargnants de même
l'article 7 terre impose aux
prestataires de services bancaire ou
financiers le respect de leurs
engagements contractuels en cours
d'exécution du contrat et l'article 13
renforce les pouvoirs du collège de
l'autorité de l'auto du collège de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers en lui
permettant d'asseoir ses injonctions
d'une astreinte nous avons toujours
soutenu les mécanismes visant à assurer
le bon fonctionnement des dispositions
de contrôle et cela ne fera pas
exception
idem pour la sécurisation du champ de
compétences de la MF pour les offres au
public de part sociale comme les banques
mutualistes ou les sociétés coopératives
enfin l'interdiction de la perception de
commission de mouvement sur le marché de
l'épargne va dans le sens des mesures
que nous avions défendu et adoptés dans
le cadre de notre proposition de loi sur
l'encadrement des frais bancaires je
n'ai pas citer tous les articles mais je
le dis au nom de mon groupe la plupart
d'entre eux vont donc dans le bon sens
car il renforce a priori la régulation
des marchés de l'épargne cependant et
nous en avons nous l'avons évoqué en
commission nous avons regretté la
présence de deux mesures de nature plus
fiscale en l'occurrence de démesure de
défiscalisation qui change la portée
d'un texte au départ je pense davantage
consensuel sur la protection des
épargnants je me félicite donc que les
rapporteurs du texte et de même proposer
la suppression de l'article 6 en
commission même si c'est dans l'attente
d'un rapport sur le sujet qui risque de
ne pas nous rendre davantage favorable
cela fait évoluer évidemment de le
regard que nous porte le groupe
socialiste sur le texte d'aujourd'hui
dans son ensemble
il reste néanmoins quelques éléments qui
relèvent à notre avis davantage de
mesures fiscales que de protection des
épargnants je pense à l'article 5 qui
élargit l'avantage fiscal attaché au
plan d'épargne en action les PEA avec le
garde-fou introduit en commission cette
disposition est basée sur un mécanisme
préventif et correctif qui ne devrait
cependant pas ou très peu créé des faits
et surtout l'article 8 proroge une
disposition d'optimisation fiscale
introduite dans la loi pacte pour un
transfert de somme d'un contrat
d'assurance vie faire un plan d'épargne
retraite
en pleine manifestation même si nous
sommes dans cette remise cycle contre la
réforme des retraites et alors que
partout dans notre pays la mobilisation
est très importante l'adoption d'un tel
dispositif ne paraît pour ainsi dire pas
opportun et je leur dirai pas du tout
même nous défonce nous défendrons donc
dans la discussion un amendement de
suppression de cet article et j'ai bien
noté la vie favorable des auteurs du
texte au retrait du dispositif afin de
bien rester dans l'objet de la
protection des épargnants mes chers
collègues vous l'aurez donc compris nous
ne sommes pas opposés à ce texte qui je
viens va dans le sens des mesures déjà
défendues par notre groupe sur les frais
bancaires ou sur la capacité d'emprunt
des personnes fragiles ils participent à
faire bénéficier les Français d'un peu
plus de concurrence et de transparence
en matière d'assurance vie et nous avons
bien entendu les résistances exprimées
par les assureurs en particulier sur la
trans rentabilité externe argument
d'ailleurs comme souvent repris presque
mot pour mot par le gouvernement et
cette situation montre bien quand la
matière nous ne pouvons pas tout
attendre de la bonne volonté des banques
et de leur capacité d'autres ou de leur
volonté d'autorégulation et qu'il est
nécessaire de légiférer pour rétablir un
équilibre entre les Français épargnants
et le système bancaire et assurantiel
d'autre part donc sous réserve de la
discussion des articles et des
amendements bien sûr la position du
groupe socialiste sur l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi devrait être
favorable je vous remercie
merci chers collègues c'est maintenant
Pascal ça vole de lit qui prend la
parole pour le groupe CRCE et pour 5
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre
collègue albéric de Montgolfier l'auteur
de la loi Me questionnait avec humeur et
humour à 14 ans en commission sur ma
présence il me demandait si j'étais
gréviste
je vais le rassurer
j'apporte mon total soutien au grévistes
et aux manifestations dans tout le pays
signe que la démocratie sociale se
mobilise massivement lorsque ces
intérêts fondamentaux sont menacés
les retraites sont au cœur de notre
modèle social et difficile de pas voir
dans cette proposition de loi un agenda
pour le moins troublant
ce texte encourage par défaut quand même
la retraite par capitalisation c'est un
projet politique cohérent que
d'affaiblir la retraite par répartition
ici par des exonérations de cotisation
là par des incitations l'épargne de
Retraite Individuelle excusez-moi mais
votre complicité certes
en construction avec le gouvernement sur
le projet de loi de retraite trouve dans
ce texte des profs supplémentaires d'une
visée commune vous vous proposez de
protéger les épargnants vous avez raison
et par non ça sonne mieux que rentier et
je vous rappelle une étude du Crédit
Mutuel une étude du Crédit Mutuel cité
par l'Observatoire des inégalités qui
démystifient l'explosion de l'épargne
durant la crise sanitaire entre fin 2019
et fin 2020 les 5% les mieux dotés en
patrimoine écoutez-moi bien ont augmenté
de 21000 euros leur dépôt bancaires
compte courant livré des pins quand on
action assurance vie tandis que les 50%
patrimoines financiers le plus modeste
non économisé que 800 euros sur l'année
un grand nombre à générer 10 madeleines
ni billets sous le matelas ils se sont
tout simplement endettés que ceux qui
n'ont pas d'épargne que ceux qui n'ont
pas d'épargne financiarisées cesse de
suivre nos débats ils ne sont pas
concernés
la suppression par les auteurs eux-mêmes
de la seule mesure de suppression des
frais des commissions de mouvement à
l'article 1er est un recul important
c'était le seul qui tendait au moins
lutter contre les gaji des produits des
pains de financières je m'excuse mais
vous légiférer sous une autorité c'est
vrai et vous l'avez dit encore cet
après-midi sous une autorité c'est celle
des marchés financiers en revanche cette
proposition de soi tente bel et bien de
protéger les épargnants qui privilégie
des plans d'épargne retraite et autres
assurance vie pour se mettre à l'abri de
leur vieux jours ou plus certainement
pour mettre à l'abri de l'administration
fiscale des sommes colossales je dis
colossal l'encours de l'assurance vie
s'élève à 2237 milliards en 2022 les
plans d'épargne retraite les per c'est
280 milliards d'euros Bruno Le Maire qui
a pas pu venir encore cet après-midi se
félicite et la droite sénatoriale
l'encourage je le cite le ministre le
maire quand il est pas obligé de parler
à sa place le déploiement du PER est un
succès majeur se produit d’épargne
retraite permet aux Français de disposer
d'un produit d'épargne avantageux pour
préparer leur retraite enfin quai
d'ironie
un succès tel que l'encourt de 70
milliards du nouveau per créé par la loi
pacte provient pour soit dans 19% des
anciens produits des plans d'épingle
retraite la loi pacte au moins une
mérite de remplacer le nommé plan
d'épargne retraite populaire créé par
François Fillon par un plan d'épargne
individuel qui dit là c'est vrai mieux
son nom le rapporteur général et son
prédécesseur ont décidé de supprimer
l'article 8 c'était notre volonté
également
pas de prolongation du double avantage
fiscal sur la conversion des produits
d'assurance vie en plan d'épargne
retraite vous évitez ainsi de mettre de
l'huile sur le feu
mais tout de même que tous ceux qui se
mobilisent en ce moment même partout en
France prennent le temps d'écouter un
instant je me lance dans le conseil
fiscal en citant Mariam Karoui ingénieur
patrimonial au cabinet Haussmann
patrimoine je la cite nous recommandons
principalement le PER a des personnes
imposées à
41%. vous m'avez bien entendu à 41%
c'est la tranche d'imposition marginale
de ceux qui ont près de 80000 euros de
revenus fiscaux de référence excusez-moi
d'appeler ça une paille je reprends une
question du média spécialisé option
finance et je vous la pose je cite même
si elle se développe l'éping retraite
restaurateurs en conséquence un marché
de niche réservait une petite minorité
de la population en mesure d'épargner
fortement vous avez compris que j'avais
une petite idée mais vous me direz si je
me trompe l'article 9 poursuit la même
finalité de favoriser la retraite par
capitalisation par l'entremise de la
Caisse des Dépôts or la retraite par
capitalisation c'est déjà le chacun pour
soi alors même que la solidarité
intergénérationnelle doit être
sanctualisée alors même que l'épargne la
plus sûre et la plus juste et la
socialisation des salaires par les
cotisations même alors même que depuis
90 les peurs alimentaires c'est
incroyable il y a eu des discours et des
réformes alarmistes qui ont fait croire
au travers de spi qu'il n'aurait pas de
retraite c'est pour ça qu'il s'adonne à
des placements financier dont il ne
connaissent ni les finalités sociales ni
les finalités écologistes alors mes
chers collègues nous voterons près de la
moitié des dispositions de cette loi par
contre nous ne voterons pas le texte
parce que franchement ce texte évacue le
rendement social et écologique je dis
bien le chiffre et les vérifiables de
5727 milliards d'épargues populaires qui
sont à nos yeux pas traités dans ce
projet de loi merci de votre attention
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Michel Canevet
qui a 8 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
les rapporteurs généraux de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues
il y a eu il y a peu de temps la formule
travaillait plus pour gagner plus elle
était bien connue effectivement mais ne
rapporteurs généraux ici ont trouvé une
autre formule qui est payé moins pour
gagner plus
c'est aussi c'est aussi pas mal parce
que c'était le le titre de leur rapport
en 2021 sur la protection des épargnants
qui formulaient 17 recommandations et le
groupe de l'Union centriste tient bien
sûr à féliciter albéric de Montgolfier
et Jean-François Husson pour le travail
qui avait ainsi été mené qui était
important et qui aboutit ce jour à
l'examen de la proposition de loi en fin
alors
Pascali vient à l'instant de citer les
chiffres effectivement
il y a dans notre pays un peu moins de
6000 milliards d'épargne des ménages le
ministre de l'économie est des finances
ce week-end évoqué ces préoccupations
contre la dette de la France elle est de
3000 milliards c'est-à-dire qu'on parle
ici en termes d'épargne de deux fois la
dette de la France c'est-à-dire qu'on
est sur des sommes tout à fait
considérables et si la dette constitue
une préoccupation et nous présent nous
au niveau du groupe de l'Union centriste
les préoccupations du ministre de
l'économie et des finances à ce sujet
dette nous avons à côté une épargne qui
est abondante et par rapport à ce qui
vient d'être dit à l'instant je dirais
que c'est pas un gros mot que de vouloir
épargner je crois que c'est la volonté
de beaucoup de nos concitoyens français
ils le font bien sûr sur différents
supports et les supports de l'assurance
vie sont tout à fait significatifs
puisque il y a grosso modo un Français
sur trois qui dispose d'un contrat
d'assurance vie un petit peu moins pour
un total de l'ordre de 2000 milliards
c'est dire qu'il y a au-delà aussi des
enjeux financiers extrêmement importants
alors qu'a-t-on observé notamment à la
lecture des rapports et des conclusions
des rapports qui ont été présentés par
nos collègues bah c'est tout simplement
que c'était une réelle opacité sur la
réalité des frais que l'on paye au titre
de cette épargne et cette situation
n'est pas pour nous acceptable pour nous
les membres du groupe de l'Union centrée
c'est pas acceptable parce que il est
légitime que tous ceux qui est un
patrimoine qui est de l'épargne sache
combien ça leur coûte effectivement dès
lors que c'était épargne et d'autant
plus confiée à des interlocuteurs à des
acteurs sur le marché et donc on
s'aperçoit finalement que c'est la plus
grande opacité sur le sujet et il était
nécessaire qu'il y ait une transparence
cela fut fait d'ailleurs pour ce qui
concerne les comptes bancaires courants
de nos concitoyens qui disposent d'une
information annuelle sur l'état des
frais qu'il paye il était logique aussi
qu'il y ait la même chose pour ce qui
concerne la part de l'épargne et je ne
doute pas que les propositions qui sont
formulées par les rapporteurs cet
après-midi seront enrichis des
propositions des membres du groupe de
l'Union centriste moi-même et Hervé
Moret nous avons déposé des amendements
en ce sens permettant à notre avis
d'enrichir les propositions de des
rapporteurs alors parmi ces questions de
frais il y a bien sûr la question des
commissions de mouvement
ce que l'on peut regretter c'est que ce
qu'il faille attendre 2026 pour que
c'est ce commissions de mouvement cela a
été dit par albéric de Montgolfier dans
son propos liminaire c'est une
singularité française et donc il
paraissait normal qu'elle soit supprimée
nous aurions souhaité qu'on aille un peu
plus vite parce que elle ne se justifie
plus à notre sens mais
nous tiendrons à la position définie par
par les rapporteurs alors cette
proposition de loi est également
l'occasion d'évoquer d'autres frais qui
sont payés par par les épargnants je
pense en particulier à la proposition
d'Hervé Moret là encore sur ce qu'on
appelle les frais sur succession
effectivement là aussi on constate qu'il
y a des pratiques totalement disparaître
souvent opaque et il importe que tout
cela soit bien cadré parce que il n'est
pas légitime à notre sens que l'on
profite de situation
difficile pour prélever une part des
ressources des ménages notamment les
ménages les plus modestes donc merci à
notre collègue Hervé Moret d'avoir
formulé des propositions en ce sens
c'est extrêmement important et puis pour
nous
membres du groupe de l'Union centriste
il y a la question de la transférabilité
qui est aussi quelque chose d'important
la loi pacte avait consacré cette
transférabilité en interne pour nous
pour moi il n'y a pas de raison que l'on
aille pas plus loin et que l'on
encourage pas la transférabilité externe
je crois que c'est une question de
respect de la concurrence c'est une
question aussi de respect du choix des
épargnants car il n'est pas tout de
considérer qu'il paye par exemple trop
de frais mais s'ils ne peuvent pas
changer de support
constatant qu'effectivement il paye trop
de frais cela paraîtrait anormal donc
moi je dis que il est légitime que l'on
puisse effectivement transférer des
comptes je veux bien entendre monsieur
le ministre qu'il y a quelques
précautions à prendre et je souscris
totalement aux propositions que le
rapporteur général Jean-François Husson
a formulé en ce sens tant dans le temps
peut éventuellement aussi mettre des
garde-refou sur les sommes susceptibles
d'être transférés mais je crois qu'il
est impératif que l'on puisse avancer
sur cette transférabilité l'exemple
qu'il a cité tout à l'heure sur
la transférabilité interne qui avait été
décrié au moment où la loi pacte avait
été examinée la situation d'aujourd'hui
montre bien qu'il n'y a pas de raison de
s'inquiéter et qu'on peut aller beaucoup
plus loin dans le sens à la fois de la
transparence et de la latitude laisser à
nos concitoyens alors un autre sujet qui
paraît important pour nous membres du
groupe de l'Union centriste c'est bien
sûr l'orientation de cette épargne il
est d'abord légitime que le maximum
d'épargne puisse être orienté vers
l'économie donc nous avons à travailler
pour que justement il en soit ainsi et
puis nous considérons également c'est le
sens de quelques amendements que j'ai
déposé qu'il est important que l'on
prenne en compte les préoccupations
d'aujourd'hui qui sont notamment la
transition écologique de notre pays et
donc pour y arriver on sait que cela
nécessite des moyens si cela nécessite
des moyens il convient d'orienter autant
que faire ce peu l'épargne vers ses
investissements qui sont considérés
comme essentiels pour l'avenir de notre
pays et donc je vous invite messieurs
les rapporteurs à reconsidérer votre
position sur ces amendements destinés à
orienter l'épargne vers les la finance
verte parce que il y a vraiment un enjeu
d'avenir un enjeu d'accélération de
cette transition écologique qui est bien
entendu posée puis je voudrais conclure
mon propos en
remercions aussi leur apporteur albéric
de Montgolfier d'avoir introduit dedans
la question de la transparence sur les
produits de défiscalisation de
l'immobilier effectivement on constate
que bien nombre beaucoup de concitoyens
se forment sur le sujet il convient
d'être beaucoup plus transport merci de
votre attention merci beaucoup cher
collègue maintenant la parole de
président Jean-Claude Riquier pour son
groupe du RDSE
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
messieurs les auteurs et rapporteurs mes
chers collègues passer la période
budgétaire la commission des finances
retrouve le temps de se pencher sur le
sujet plus spécifiques c'est le câble
cette proposition de loi tu en as
renforcer la protection des épargnommes
alors que son grand retour dans la
sécurité économique supposant cette
année environ après des années il faut
le dire d'influration faible voire nulle
l'épargne français est entré dans une
nouvelle zone de risque l'inflation
elle-même conjuguez à l'évolution
parfois graphique des valeurs boursières
et des taux d'intérêts encore bas malgré
une nette remontée à voir s'il y a un an
tendre à éroder la valeur des formes
placées en produits d'épargne rappelons
que tolé par les moyens des Français
l'un des plus élevés des pays développés
et ceci est l'inquiétude collective face
à l'avenir ou d'un pessimiste souvent
attribué à notre peuple ou bien
simplement d'une plus grande prévoyance
ancré dans la culture nationale en tout
cas on est loin du comportement des
cigales
quand vous voulez souvent prêté à nos
concitoyens il y a plus d'un siècle la
phrase était considérée comme le
banquier du monde une population encore
majoritairement rurale
habitué à économiser et dans l'état les
plus fait défauts sur sa dette depuis la
Révolution jouer alors d'une puissance
financière exceptionnelle avec toutefois
des communes historiques comme l'affaire
des emplois russe pendant la Première
Guerre mondiale où les nombreuses
scandales financiers qui ont Évaillé
l'histoire de la Troisième République
revenons au présent en 2021 le taux
d'épargne des ménages en France était
égal à 18,7% du revenu disponible brut
il a Mendi il a bondit en 2020 avec
l'épargne contrainte du au restrictions
sanitaire sur l'angle période il est
d'une assez grande stabilité autour de
15%
en comparaison aux États-Unis le taux
sur le long terme aussi autour de 6%
seulement et en Allemagne et autour de
10%, seule la Suisse affiche un taux
d'épargne supérieur à la France en plus
la conjoncture actuelle les auteurs la
proposition de loi considèrent que le
marché français épargne souffre de
défauts structurels au détriment des
épargne la majorité de l'épargne des
Français est placé sur des comptes
bancaires délivrés réglementés
c'est-à-dire des placements plus risqués
mais également assez peu de rémunérateur
quoique peu ou pas imposer l'archétype
et le livret A dans le taux remonte
actuellement faut-il pour autant se
diriger vers une gestion de l'épargne à
l'américaine avec aussi les risques
qu'une telle gestion comporte gageons
que ce ne sont pas l'objectif des
auteurs de cette PPL il est vrai en
revanche que les différents frais liés à
la gestion de l’épargne représente des
montants non négligeables pour les
épargnants et souvent assez mal connu
je vais prendre ma retraite dans mon
collègue Christian Billac commission des
finances l'année dernière il était
important de revenir à une information
claire et surtout personnalisée adapté
aux beaux seins du client et s'il faut
plutôt une information sur la valeur
nette des placements que sur la valeur
brute et autant d'informations sur les
frais potentiels que sur les plus values
potentiels
par les auteurs de la PPL de site un
particulier faisant le choix de
commencer à épargner très tôt pour sa
retraite pour avoir la performance de
ces placements à 40 ans capté à plus de
55% par les frais confiez-vous ces
chiffres comment s'explique-t-il les
chapitres seront cadrement des frais et
de la meilleure transparence à presque
une bonne mesure pour des opérations
dans l'épargnant la soit même pas
connaissance je l'interroge bien fonder
des article 5 bis assouplissant
lisibilité des PEA des fonds en PEA des
fonds de placement à risque je qui
réserve sur le disposition de l'article
16 et elle m'a introduit en commission
et qui supprime le délit d'entrar aux
enquêtes et contrôle de l'Autorité des
marchés financiers pour les remplacer
par une simple action administrative
l'article 7 qui prolonge une mesure déjà
votée dans la loi pacte assura une
transférabilité complet de l'assurance
vie serait un réel projet dans la mesure
où il donnerait une liberté bien
supérieure à l'épargnant dans la
question de ces placements en conclusion
les membres du RDS salut la qualité du
travail accompli par les auteurs de
texte Jean-François Husson et organique
de Montgolfier et devrait se prononcer
par sur l'adoption à moins que des
modifications importantes ne soient
apportées en cours de séance
la parole est à Madame Christine Lavarde
pour le groupe des Républicains
et elle dispose de 4 minutes
merci monsieur le Président alors sans
trop de surprise mon propos va se
concentrer sur l'article 7 en effet il y
a 4 ans jour pour jour dans cette
émission j'ai défendu un amendement qui
visait à autoriser la transférabilité
externe des contrats d'assurance vie
alors à l'époque le ministre le maire
c’était opposé et il m'a fait proposer
de retravailler ensemble sur la
concurrence entre les produits
d'assurance vie alors j'attends toujours
l'invitation 4 ans plus tard
heureusement le Sénat lui a continué à
travailler alors je voudrais revenir sur
deux sujets déjà la transfertilité
interne au sein d'une même entreprise
d'assurance vie sorte de pisalée qu'on
nous avait accordé à l'issue de la
commission mixte paritaire alors j'ai
bien entendu cet après-midi que le
gouvernement soutient pleinement toutes
les démarches qui visent à conforter ce
principe alors il existe encore un
certain nombre de freins de difficultés
qui sont rencontrés au quotidien par les
acteurs concernant la transfertilité
interne en effet la moindre faille la
moindre imprécision législatives est
utilisée par les assureurs ou les
courtiers pour ne pas donner droit aux
demandes des clients parce qu'ils sont
en quelque sorte toujours réticents à
cette transfertilité et donc les
amendements qui ont été adoptés en
commission des finances à l'initiative
des rapports vont dans le bon sens moi
il me semble qu'il y a encore un certain
nombre de points qui pourraient être
précisé c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai déposé deux amendements en ce sens
mais surtout le gouvernement par la
bouche du ministre barreau vient de nous
dire cet après-midi qu'il continuait à
s'opposer à la transfertilité externe et
deux arguments sont souvent exposés sur
lesquels je voudrais revenir alors déjà
la transférabilité externe par les
sorties qu'elles entraînent empêcherait
le bon financement de l'économie alors
je voudrais juste vous rappeler monsieur
le ministre qu'aujourd'hui les
compagnies d'assurance elles sont
obligées de respecter un certain nombre
de ratios qui sont fixés par le code des
assurances elle doit aussi respecter la
directive européenne solven donc vous
voyez bien il y a que ce c'est ce cadre
là réglementaire qui impose les
différents ratios et la nature la
proportion d'active que doit détenir les
compagnies d'assurance et donc la
transfertilité externe elle n'aura
absolument aucune conséquence sur ces
différents ratios et elles ne viendra
pas limiter les investissements en
action enfin vous nous avez redit à
l'instant que la transfertilité externe
parce qu'elle déclencherait des sorties
et des entrées amèneraient les assureurs
à devoir gérer des conditions de marché
qui ne leur font pas forcément toujours
favorables alors je voudrais juste quand
même vous rappeler ici l'ordre de
grandeur des mouvements qui existent
déjà en 2021 nous avons eu 148,6
milliards de versements en assurance vie
nous avons eu 126,2 milliards de rachats
donc là vous voyez bien que c'est des
mouvements avec des qui entraînent des
conséquences sur la gestion de
portefeuille des assureurs je prends
aussi le rapport de France assurance de
France assureur pardon qui vous donne
les chiffres de la transférabilité sur
2021 657
000 contrats ont été transférés en 2020
et 2021 pour un montant de 21,9
milliards d'euros et au premier semestre
2022 le mouvement poursuit en essor 128
000 transferts de contrat pour 4,5
milliards d'euros tout ça a bien
évidemment à rapporter au volume
d'encours de l'assurance vie qui a été
rappelé mille
1874 milliards d'euros alors juste pour
vous le dire dans le cadre de la
transférabilité interne les fonds du
contrat du contrat a sont vendus et
réinvestis ensuite dans le contrat B
pour la part en euros compris aussi et
aujourd'hui j'entends pas les assureurs
se plaindre de ces problèmes de
transférabilité je les entends pas non
plus se plaindre quand ils doivent gérer
des mouvements de rachat de la part de
leurs clients alors pourquoi aujourd'hui
et c'est des choses qui existent depuis
longtemps le transfertilité externe qui
va pas entraîner du jour au lendemain
des mouvements de déstabilisation d'une
import mortel je rappelle toujours
l'encourt total
1874 milliards entraînerait des craintes
de la part du gouvernement si c'est
juste à nous dire que vous avez peur que
des compagnies d'assurance en difficulté
puissent être mis à mal par des clients
qui ont peur alors pourquoi doit-on
sauver des assureurs zombies c'est la
question que je vous pose
paroles
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe des indépendants
et pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
146 milliards 146 milliards d'euros
c'est le montant consacré
et constaté pardon enfin juillet par la
Banque de France de la surépargne
accumulée par les Français depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire
c'est plus que le montant du plan de
relance c'est plus aussi que le montant
des mesures de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat
le phénomène est désormais bien connu
avec les mesures de restriction
sanitaire la consommation a chuté alors
que les mesures de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat ou préserver les revenus des
ménages
en conséquence l'épargne a explosé et
atteint des sommets sans précédent
mais ce que révèle l'étude de la Banque
de France paru en septembre dernier
c'est que ce phénomène perdure alors
même que les restrictions sanitaires ont
été levées
cette surépargne covid nous rappelle que
les pannes constituent d'abord un moyen
de se protéger surtout quand l'avenir
est assombri par les incertitudes or ce
qui a changé depuis mars 2020 c'est que
notre pays a renoué avec l'inflation
alors que la plupart des économistes
pensaient que ce phénomène ne nous
concernait plus du tout
l'inflation constitue aujourd'hui la
principale menace pour les pannes des
Français elle lançaient en effet dans un
étau d'une part parce que les prix
augmentent la fraction de la
consommation dans le revenu des ménages
augmente aussi ce qui mécaniquement
diminue la fraction affectée à l'épargne
d'autre part la hausse des taux
d'intérêt qui accompagne l'inflation ne
suffit pas à compenser l'augmentation
des prix on le voit avec le taux du
livret A récemment réhaussé à 3 % bien
en deçà du taux de l'inflation en
conséquence l'épargne de nos concitoyens
a tendance à s'éroder
c'est pourquoi je tiens à saluer la
proposition de loi présentée par nos
collègues albéric de Montgolfier et
Jean-François Husson pour protéger les
épargnants leur travail a été engagé
bien avant l'envolée de l'inflation dont
je fais par notamment avec un rapport
d'information qui a été publié en
octobre 2021 dont la proposition de loi
présente reprend les recommandations
d'ordre législatif il s'agit pas d'un
texte de circonstances mais les
circonstances actuelles le rendent
encore plus pertinent si la plupart des
articles y compris les nombreux qui ont
été rajoutés en Commission semble très
technique ils apportent des mesures
bienvenues pour les épargnants c'est
notamment le cas pour l'article 7 qui
garantit une réelle transférabilité des
contrats d'assurance vie
une telle mesure devrait rendre le
marché plus concurrentiel et donc
améliorer les prestations de gestion de
ces produits elle donne également
davantage de liberté aux épargnants en
leur permettant de choisir l'option qui
leur convient le mieux nous l'avons vu
encore récemment avec la résiliation à
tout moment des contrats d'assurance
crédit les Français se sont emparés de
cette nouvelle liberté
ils le feront désormais aussi à leur
avantage pour faire jouer la concurrence
en matière de contrat d'assurance vie
dans le même esprit je tiens aussi à
saluer l'assouplissement des critères
d'éligibilité des quotas des FCPR au PEA
cela favorise le financement capital
risque notamment pour les jeunes
entreprises innovantes et tout ce qui
finance notre économie particulièrement
par les temps qui courent étant
encouragé la proposition loi porte
également plusieurs mesures dans le
cadrement et de régulation elle vise à
protéger les épargnants contre des
pratiques qui pourraient les induire en
erreur cependant certaines de ces
mesures risquent de manquer d'efficacité
car on le sait bien mes chers collègues
les opérateurs et notamment les banques
trouvent toujours un chemin pour les
contourner c'est un cycle bien connu
s'agissant de la régulation bancaire
certaines pratiques soulèvent des
indignations le législateur légifère et
les banques finissent par contourner ces
interdictions sous le vent toujours de
nouvelles indignations
dans ce cas il est à craindre que la
régulation des pratiques bancaires ne
soit un travail à la saisie jamais
achevé toujours à recommencer
dans le registre des pratiques bancaires
peut recommanda mes chers collègues il
en est une qui a soulevé l'indignation
du public grâce notamment à une
publication du magazine UFC Que Choisir
que nos concitoyens connaissent bien il
s'agit du prélèvement de frais bancaire
sur le compte des défunts je vous
proposerai un amendement pour encadrer
très strictement ces pratiques cet
amendement reprend en partie une
proposition de loi que j'avais déposé
sur le sujet voici près d'un an j'espère
que notre assemblée pourra les juiférer
sur ce point afin d'envoyer un message
fort pour mettre un terme assez pratique
qui ajoute de l'indignation à la peine
des familles qui est quand la confiance
que les Français peuvent avoir dans
leurs institutions bancaires vous
l'aurez compris notre groupe soutiendra
cette proposition de loi qui va dans le
bon sens et je vous engage mes chers
collègues à voter pour les amendements
que nous proposerons je vous remercie
merci chers collègues c'est parfait pour
le timing maintenant la parole est à
Monsieur Daniel Breuillet pour 5 minutes
également
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues tout d'abord je voudrais
saluer les travaux de contrôle du Sénat
et de sa commission des finances sous
l'impulsion de nos collègues de
Mongolfier et Jean-François Husson le
groupe écologiste soutient les mesures
qui visent à accroître la transparence
dans tous les domaines et singulièrement
dans le domaine bancaire et à amoindrir
les frais d'épargne la double charge
pour les épargnants et particulièrement
unique et votre proposition de loi en
interdisant notamment la perception de
commission de mouvement tant à répondre
à cette problématique comme la
transparence accrue sur les
investissements immobiliers absolument
nécessaires
toutefois ne partageons pas votre vision
et vos propositions sur les contraintes
du marché au chapitre 3 quand vous
voulez notamment encourager les
épargnants à mobiliser le répargne au
profit des entreprises cette thèse
néoclassique de la hausse de l'épargne
qui bénéficie toujours à l'économie
n'est pas la nôtre parce que pour être
efficiente il faut qu'elle soit orientée
vers la transition écologique de
l'activité économique et sans doute
aussi vers l'économie sociale et
solidaire plusieurs amendements
l'évoquent plutôt que sur la
financiarisation de cette épargne la
période d'inflation que nous traversons
frappe de plein fouet les petits
épargnants et je pense bien sûr au 55
millions de détenteurs d'un livret A et
plus particulièrement à tous les foyers
modestes qui ont un encours inférieur à
1500 euros ce sont eux effectivement
qu'il convient d'abord de protéger et
ils sont nombreux et nombreux eux à
avoir d'abord et déjà du renoncer à une
partie de leur épargne pendant les
confinements quand effectivement les
plus d'entre nous augmentaient
considérablement le épargne les plus
modestes étaient souvent contraints de
la consommer la limitation des frais et
la transparence sont donc nécessaires
pour ces personnes modestes car la
réduction des inégalités doit toujours
demeurer la priorité nous sommes là au
cœur du problème il est indispensable de
rétablir une fiscalité juste sur les
revenus des épargnes accumulés ce
patrimoine ne dort pas il génère des
revenus supplémentaires pour les ménages
les plus aisés mais encore plus pour les
établissements financiers et depuis la
mise en place de la flat tax à 30% en
2018 ses revenus sont moins taxés que
ceux du travail je profite de ce texte
pour rappeler à cette occasion que notre
groupe est opposé et souhaite la même
imposition pour le travail que pour les
revenus financiers
je souhaite enfin parler un instant de
l'impact social et environnemental des
comptes bancaires et de l'importance de
réguler les activités des banques objets
de la proposition de loi ce sujet
soulevé par Oxfam France en 2020
démontrait combien notre argent mis en
banque finance potentiellement de
projets en France comme à
l'international et révélait l'empreinte
carbone colossale des banques françaises
les activités de financement et
d'investissement des six principales
banques françaises représentent près de
8 fois les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de la France entière il est donc
urgent de réguler les banques françaises
Oxfam France recommande d'ailleurs de
créer un label en transition qui
pourrait venir éclairer et définir un
degré d'alignement d'un portefeuille
avec l'accord de Paris sur le climat
nous soutenons bien évidemment cette
initiative concernant cette proposition
de loi elle est bienvenu sur la
protection des épargnants et d'exigences
de plus de transparence et ne répond
peut-être pas suffisamment aux enjeux de
justice fiscale sociale et
environnemental que nous défendons nous
avons un doute notamment sur la question
de la transférabilité externe mais
j'écouterai avec intérêt les débats et
les réponses cette proposition introduit
à l'article 8 un lien au débat en cours
sur la retraite que nous ne pouvons
souvenirs soutenir et je salue la vie
favorable donné à l'amendement de
retrait de cet article chers collègue le
débat sur ce texte m'a contrarié non
pour son contenu mais parce qu'il m'a
imposé de rentrer trop rapidement de la
manifestation contre une réforme de
retraite que je juge injuste inefficace
et inutile malgré cela nous serons
attentifs à l'écoute des argumentaires
et prendront notre décision vu du
traitement des amendements présentés
merci chers collègues
la parue maintenant monsieur Vincent
Segoin pour les républicains et dispose
de 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'assurance vie est
aujourd'hui le placement préféré des
Français on l'a dit avec 45 % des
ménages qui possèdent un contrat en
assurance vie presque 50 millions de
contre-individuels répertoriés pour un
total de près de 2000 milliards en cours
la durée moyenne de détention d'un
contrat en assurance vie et de 12 ans
qui permet au gestionnaire du secteur
bancaire et assurantiel d'accompagner le
dettes des états et le développement des
entreprises sur le long terme
cependant avec la chute des taux
d'intérêts la rémunération des fonds
euros et passer de 5,3% en 2000 à 0,8%
2022 a subi d'importantes conséquences
poussant les gestionnaires orienter les
épargnants vers les unités de compte de
la rémunération est plus attractive mais
aussi plus risqué
ces unités de compte sont des
investissements confiés à des
gestionnaires de fonds avec des
orientations ciblées sur les actions
obligations nationales européennes
internationales comme les fonds verts ou
j'en passe la rémunération des
épargnants est donc aujourd'hui plus
aléatoire moins sûr moins linéaire car
plus risqué mais sur le temps long plus
favorable de même il apparaît plus
éthique d'investir sur de la valeur
d'entreprise et de la croissance que sur
de la dette des États mais il est vrai
que les frais de gestion peuvent venir
sérieusement diminuer les rémunérations
la proposition de loi de mes collègues
hussons et de Montgolfier mais en
évidence une opacité des frais qui
peinalise des épargnants à première
rapport était sorti en 2021 et a permis
certaines avancées de la part des
gestionnaires et permet l'AMF sur la
transparence des frais avec de nouvelles
obligations pour le premier janvier 2026
on en prend acte
après ce premier chapitre son
encadrement des frais la proposition de
loi de nos collègues propose aussi la
transparence de la performance des
produits qui est une condition clé pour
assurer un choix éclairé pour les
épargnants et stimulantes pour la
concurrence ces quatre premiers articles
sont donc particulièrement dirigés vers
les épargnants afin de leur garantir une
information claire et transparente pour
guider au mieux leurs choix cependant je
m'interroge sur l'ensemble des
obligations imposées au gestionnaires
dans les lettres annuelles je reste
convaincu qu'on ne remplace pas de
remplacera pas le conseil la confiance
parle des obligations et des devoirs qui
rendent l'information trop lourde et
deux hommes de moins en moins lisible
pour les épargnants
mais l'article de cette proposition de
loi qui m'apparaît le plus important et
dont la mise en place pose question à
l'ensemble des acteurs et sans doute
l'article 7 il a pour objectif de
permettre une véritable transférabilité
interne et externe des contrats
d'assurance vie au-delà de 8 ans le
transfertilité externe est actuellement
impossible et les épargnants doivent
racheter leur contrat au risque de
perdre davantage fiscal à qui au-delà
des 8 ans la transférabilité interne est
aussi compliqué et dépend du bon vouloir
des gestionnaires en cas de refus trop
souvent l'épargnant rachète et ne
remplace plus forcément les sommes sur
l'assurance vie qui est pourtant censée
de suivre tout au long de sa vie
prenons un exemple vous avez un souscrit
un contrat d'assurance vie il y a 8 ans
chez un gestionnaire de patrimoine qui a
placé dans une compagnie le gestionnaire
de patrimoine n'est plus là aujourd'hui
et la compagnie a été rachetée par une
autre compagnie qui ne souhaite plus
avoir de réseau physique votre situation
change et vous souhaitez faire le point
il n'y a plus personne vous allez voir
donc un nouveau conseiller qui vous
avise de renforcer des versements sur
l'assurance vie pour préparer vos
prochaines étapes de la vie il aura
alors l'obligation de vous conseiller de
le faire sur le contrat existant car il
bénéficie de l'antériorité fiscale de 8
ans
c'est une obligation voulue par
l'autorité de contrôle et législateurs
qui entravent dorénavant le choix
d'épargnant certes le législateur a
souhaité rendre répréhensible des actes
commerciaux qui désavantage des clients
mais attention aux limites de ces lois
l'absence de transfertilité empêche donc
l'épargnant de faire les bons choix et
d'opter pour les conditions qui
correspondent le mieux à sa situation
personnelle et à ces objectifs c'est
pourquoi je suis favorable à
transférabilité à la condition que la
durée minimale de 8 ans soit respectée
cependant la crainte des gestionnaires
qui s'inquiètent du nombre de rachats et
de l'obligation de garder une réserve
pour répondre à ces demandes
j'entends aussi leurs réserves
quant à
la part d'épargne qui ne pourront plus
placer pour répondre au rachat avec un
risque de performance qui diminue
au final je suis désolé mais je ne crois
pas aux risques majeur que cela puisse
entraîner et la transférabilité
apportant à plus de confiance aux
épargnants qui pourront changer de
gestionnaire ou d'intermédiaire
conclusion comme le groupe LR je suis
favorable
[Applaudissements]
et pour trois minutes
mais je me suis le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur les rapporteurs
généraux mais chers collègues
aujourd'hui nous débattons de la
concrétisation législative du long
travail de nos rapporteurs généraux
monsieur de Montgolfier monsieur Husson
sur un sujet structurant tant pour le
pouvoir d'achat des Français que pour le
financement d'économie j'adresse mes
remerciements aux deux rapporteurs pour
cette belle opportunité mon intervention
portera sur deux points d'abord le
modèle de rémunération des produits
d'épargne qui fait l'objet de débat tant
au niveau européen qu'au cours des
travaux de la mission d'information qui
a précédé cette PPL pour moi au cœur de
la protection des épargnants le conseil
financier doit demeurer accessible au
plus grand nombre d'épargnants et ne
doit pas être réservé aux seuls ménage
qui peuvent s'acquitter d'honoraires le
modèle de commissionnement actuel doit
être préservé les risques sont cont par
nos régulateurs nationaux aujourd'hui un
épargnant trouve normal d'être conseillé
par un salarié de la banque ou de
l'assureur puisqu'il a choisi et qui lui
vend le produit à l'inverse celui qui ne
peut pas se payer une prestation de
conseils réalisera ses investissements
seuls devant son écran sur des
plateformes plus ou moins encadrées qui
rentreront vers des produits à la mode
comme certains crypto actifs pour ne
citer que cet exemple
le deuxième point c'est porte pour
l'assurance vie comme beaucoup de mes
collègues depuis 18 ans ici au Sénat
nous avons fait progresser le placement
préféré des Français d'abord sur la
déshérence des contrats d'assurance puis
sur l'information des assurés j'y ai
modistement contribué nous avons réussi
à faire évoluer au bénéfices des assurés
malgré la frilosité des assureurs et
sans jamais fragiliser ce secteur clé de
l'économie française quoi qu'on disait à
l'origine les assureurs
tu sais pourquoi je crains messieurs les
rapporteurs que la transférabilité
totale prévue dans la PPL même avec les
garde-fous proposés naient des
conséquences sur le financement à long
terme de nos entreprises la
transférabilité réduira forcément
l'horizon des investissements et
orientera l'épargne sur des actifs de
plus court terme et moins risqués pour
pouvoir faire face à des sorties
facilités et donc importantes c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai proposé une
voie médiane
qui dynamisera l'assurance vie sans la
dynamiter avec un des amendements qui
portent à 12 ans la transférabilité
externe car seulement un tiers des
contrats d'assurance ne serait concernés
je tiens aussi à conclure pour me
réjouir de la richesse de vos travaux en
commission et sur le renforcement de la
transfert barrabilité interne qui
ouvrira de nouvelles opportunités pour
l'assurer et je ne vois pas comment et
pourquoi les assureurs pourraient si
opposer merci beaucoup cher collègue et
nous terminons la discussion générale
avec Monsieur Jean Raymond Hugonnet qui
a également 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui l'épargne des
Français atteint des sommets et plus que
jamais il nous faut veiller à la
protection des épargnants
c'était épargne sorte pourtant un manque
de transparence notamment sur les frais
et les produits disponibles
le nombre élevé d'intermédiaire
participe également à une forme
d'opacité entretenue par une concurrence
insuffisante
tout ceci tire vers le bas les
performances servies aux épargnants qui
financent pourtant ne l'oublions pas
l'économie réelle de notre pays
nous avons donc besoin d'eux comme ils
ont besoin de nous
notre responsabilité est aussi de
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
surtout en ce moment en sécurisant les
revenus complémentaires
issus des placements de nos concitoyens
l'interdiction des commissions de
mouvement
le référencement des produits
industriels à bas coût
l'amélioration de l'information
disponible sur les frais de l'assurance
vie ou encore une réelle transférabilité
de celle-ci constitue autant de pistes
évoquées par nos éminents collègues
Jean-François Husson et albéric de
Montgolfier il y a quelques mois dans
leur rapport d'information intitulée la
protection des épargnants de points
payez moins et gagner plus voilà un
véritable objectif
la proposition de loi qu'ils ont déposé
à l'issue de ce travail en profondeur
traduite au niveau législatif les justes
recommandations qu'ils ont formulé
à cet égard la transférabilité externe
des contrats d'assurance vie apparaît
comme le point faisant l'objet du plus
important débat
pour s'y opposer évidemment les banques
et assurances mettent en avant un risque
prudentiel et systémique ce qui n'a rien
d'étonnant venant d'elle
pour autant comme l’ont précisé les
rapporteurs elles n'ont rien pu prouver
avec des simulations et des chiffres
nous sommes d'ailleurs preneurs ici la
représentation nationale monsieur le
ministre nous sommes preneurs de ces
chiffres et évidemment cybersi pouvait
nous enfourner nous en serions bien
heureux alors monsieur le ministre nous
aimerions tout simplement savoir si vos
services sont en mesure d'éclairer le
débat sur ce point je vous remercie de
votre écoute merci chers collègues
cela clos la discussion générale et nous
passons à discussion du texte de la
commission et nous commençons avant
l'article premier un article additionnel
fait l'objet de l'amendement 35
monsieur Savoldelli vous pouvez le
défendre l'amendement 35
le Président je vais vous faire une
bonne proposition je vous proposer de
défendre les deux en même temps ça vous
va ça va accepter
alors adopter ouais ça serait bien mais
ça sera peut-être pas le cas donc
monsieur le Président sur le rapporteur
général mais mes chers collègues vous
portez l'ambition je cite de renforcer
la protection des épargnants mais là
aucune disposition de ce texte ne
concerne les livrets réglementés
pourtant 87 millions de livrets de ce
type sont ouverts pour un encourt total
de 846 milliards d'euros vous les
connaissez tous le livret A le Livret de
Développement le LEP etc et pour vous en
convaincre je vous dis un extrait des
observations de la Cour des comptes je
cite l'épargne réglementée constitue une
particularité française qui a peu
d'équivalent en Europe et qui s'explique
par l'histoire financière et par
l'importance des dispositifs
réglementaires visant encourager
protégés l'épargne des ménages elle
offre à ces derniers des produits
simples bénéficiant de la part de l'état
d'une garantie sur le capital et d'une
rémunération évoluant en fonction de
l'inflation pour le système financier
elle constitue une ressource stable et
contribue à transformer les dépôts des
épargnants en emploi d'intérêt général
de long terme fin de citation de la Cour
des comptes ces deux amendements
proposent d'élargir les bénéficiaires du
Livret d'Épargne Populaire et